a lot of television dramas you know like
Mad Men Game of Thrones you probably
notice they show a quick montage of
scenes from the next episode you know
you're done with the episode they show
you a montage of scenes from next week
well we thought we'd start doing this
for our show
yeah these things sometimes don't really
make sense you look at them they don't
quite make sense but we thought we'll do
it on our show so here are some scenes
from our next episode
on the next episode of Conan oh my god
your sound effects I know it's not what
I had in mind if you like arms so much
won't you just hire them
[Music]
never make a mistake that big again
please don't be blind I'll take your
silence as a No
remember what are you
what happened this weekend what else
would you wear over women's underwear
that's a mess this is
[Applause]